it's time for the lawn gene conosco a
television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
monday wednesday and fridays a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
watch company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chroma scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry lesser and
Winston brunette our distinguished guest
for this evening is the honorable
charles r howell representative from New
Jersey the Democratic parties often call
a party of the liberal north and the
conservative south well in times of
victory they've managed to overcome
their sectional differences but of
course in the last congressional
elections the last election year they
did not but will in recent days in the
Senate the Democrats managed to put
together a front on a labor bill which
rivaled the days of 1932 I don't think
it ever been equaled since then now
congressman Hal what did that unity on
that roll call vote on the killing of
the taft-hartley Hartley amendments
signify to you well mr. sorry I think we
have for some reason or other being
technically at least in the minority now
got more party unity than we've had for
a long time and of course the example of
the Senate voting solidly to recommit
the taft-hartley a revision was a the
most forceful example of that and I
think there's a lot of that going on now
but I think part of that unity on that
vote came about because different
segments of the party for different
reasons found it sensible to come to the
same conclusion on that bill the
so-called northern perhaps pro-labor
Democratic senators were afraid that
whatever came out of the proceedings
this time would would be worse than the
present bill
and many of the Southern Democrats and
conservative Democrats didn't like the
possibility of the states rights
business getting defeated and some other
things getting added to the bill so it
was a natural situation for them to
create a unified front on that
particular occasion in other words you
don't think it actually foretold a unity
that would be one which would lead the
democratic party to victory well I
wouldn't get away from that and i think
it was wonderful but i'm not sure that
it was completely that good we had an
ideal set of circumstances to bring it
about on that particular vote yes
congressman Howell the other day you
told a rally in New Jersey that you
thought the Republican Party was
hopelessly split do you have any
concrete evidence of that well of course
you got one right can't a bit of
concrete evidence and in the present
hearings where you have two different
segments or two different individuals in
the Republican Party fighting against
each other refer to the McCarthy here
yes army hearings now and it's it's
Republicans against Republicans there
and when one wing of the party so to
speak more or less against the other
wing and it's not the Republicans
investigating or trying to belittle the
Democrats and and it is a Republican
mass strictly of course that's the
forceful example of it pointed up by the
present McCarthy Stevens hearings but I
think there have been plenty of other
evidences of it on legislative matters
where President Eisenhower even when he
has some fairly good programs send down
to Congress he finds that he has to in
order to get the support of the extreme
right wing of the party he has to either
abandon some of his legislative program
or water other parts of it down or or
get it so that it is acceptable to the
extreme right wing of the Republican
Party which is against most of its
program or most of us worthwile
incidentally congressman Hal before the
hearings took place on the army McCarthy
dispute you get that time called for the
resignation of
secretary of the army Stevens now do you
still feel the same way about it now the
hearing to take place I have a lot of
sympathy for mr. Stevens and I think
he's an awfully decent guy but I think
he did make some early mistakes there of
placating Senator McCarthy by giving in
and granting a lot of favors to shine
that the ordinary gee I would just never
hope to expect and that sort of thing
isn't fair i think he went too far with
it I can sympathize with him i can
understand perhaps why he did it but i
think he ought to have been able to
stand up better than that i I think he's
got a tough job and I sympathize with
him these hearings but he he actually
didn't look very good then and he hasn't
been as forceful and effective witness
and shown the real grasp of things that
I would have hoped that he would have
shown in these hearings do you think
that this Republican Party split is
reflected in our foreign policy that
it's weakened our leadership abroad
perhaps i would say it has the old
isolationist supplied to your crown and
perhaps they might be interventionist in
in asia or the same crowd that's giving
the present administration the same
amount of trouble that they gave the the
Democratic administration previously
they almost seem to forget that they're
in power now and they're fighting the
their own administration almost as
strongly and create as much trouble as
they did under the Truman an ax in
foreign policy situation well
congressman howl in recent days various
prominent Democratic spokesman have
opened up with rather vigorous attacks
on the administration's foreign policy
and what exactly does this signify in
terms of bipartisanship does it mean an
end of it I honestly hope not and I
don't think many responsible Democrats
would want it to be interpreted that way
or would want it to work out that way
but I think there's been created here
such a vacuum and things have been going
so bad diplomatically that they feel a
responsibility to speak out and I hope
they are
in a constructive way but I think most
Democrats realize the seriousness of
what we're up against in the world today
and very much want to have a bipartisan
foreign policy they want to be called in
more they want more participation they
want Congress to have more information
and they want to see a little more
specific plan of where we're going and
in the absence of that lately I think
they felt that they had to speak out on
some of these things well I'd like to
push you further on that now that
Senator Lyndon Johnson has spoken out
and President Truman against the
administration's foreign policy do you
feel this presses a final split with the
President on his foreign policy program
as we head into the congressional
elections I really hope not and I don't
believe at this point it does amount to
that I think the broad foreign policy
under Eisenhower is the same policy that
we had under Truman and then to some
extent under Roosevelt but the the
diplomacy has been weak we've done
things or haven't done things that have
alienated or lost the cooperation of our
lives in many parts of the world we're
almost down to syngman rhee and chiang
kai-shek now at this point and it it's
making it very very difficult but I
think our broad objectives are the same
as those of the Republicans and that
with a little more consultation a little
more plan of action on the part of the
administration a little more agreement
within the administration on what
they're going to do that they'll find
the Democrats back of the myth if we can
find what to back sir what do you
foresee in this immediate Indochina
crisis do you foresee that the United
States Congress will have to take some
action this year at this session with
respect to United Allied action or
American intervention well of course
we're moving pretty fast now with the
end of Gambia few and the imminence of a
a really tough situation Hanoi something
has got to be done fairly quickly it's
it's the responsibility of the President
and Secretary Dulles to
to tell us what needs to be done and
certainly it's going to take I don't
think we can get enough out of the
negotiations at Geneva 2 to accomplish
anything very much the secretary went
there was very little in the way of
cards in his hand and then he gave away
one of the very early in the press
conference before the pauli started and
I think just at this point we we've got
to decide how far we need to go we can't
afford to one by one surrender those
important vital spots in Asia or we're
just starting a series of events that
can only wind up in disaster I think the
Democrats if they know what the policy
is and the people are back or let in on
it that will be really available for
help and then bipartisan foreign policy
things I'd like to get back to the home
front for a minute and refer to the
economic situation now what would you
Democrats have done if you had been in
for the past two years well I think
there a number of things that that could
have been done fairly recently should be
done now I don't think we're in a
depression i'm not one of the so called
prophets of gloom but i think the
republicans have lost the concept that
we need an expanding economy they seem
to be satisfied with a second best
prosperity and they don't realize that
our population increases more people
come into our working force every year
if we just went along and had the same
economic level as we had in 1953 by 1960
we could wind up with 14 millions
unemployed we need increased social
security benefits a tax policy designed
to give our economy a left we need
greater unemployment compensation
benefits we need a better manipulation
of interest rates and a possible standby
shelf of Public Works public facilities
that could be put into action quickly if
the economy shows more signs of slipping
those are some of the things that I
think they've been slow to deal with and
slow to recognize
so you don't seem to differ very much
from the president and his program is
there any possibility do you think sir
of the president getting bipartisan
support for his domestic program before
the congressional elections well that
that's much more difficult of course
you've got a more serious sense of
responsibility on Foreign Affairs it's
too vital to lessons of the whole world
economics you can play a little more
politics with sometimes but without
ruining the country perhaps but I think
there's general agreement but that the
administration has just been a little
slow and moving on some of these things
even though they recognize the dangers
of them they they've been sitting back
and expressing the hope the old
prosperity's just around the corner
philosophy and the trickle-down theory
both seem to still be existing today
thank you very much congressman house
nice to him here tonight thank you the
opinions expressed on the lawn Jean
chrono scope were those of the speakers
the editorial board for this edition of
the lawn gene Cronus cope was Larry
lesser and Winston burr deftly our
distinguished guest was the Honorable
Charles are Hollow representative from
New Jersey